general mark nelly remember he is part
of a bureaucracy that no one will ever
get fired right no one is going to lose
their job for incompetence so long as
they carry out the wishes of a
democratic president so we have watched
an extraordinarily botched operation in
afghanistan
general mark milley it is kind of
amazing that mark milley called up
the chinese to assure them that we
wouldn't do anything that offended their
tender sensibilities while trump was
president meanwhile general mark milley
in the entire pentagon was working with
the biden administration to make nice
with the taliban so that's that's really
just wonderful
and apparently droning randos so that's
exciting as well rand paul
asked
senator secretary of state tony blinken
yesterday about this because on the way
out of afghanistan
after the isis k attack which is like
the special k of isis attack on american
troops in afghanistan while they were
trying to evacuate folks you'll recall
that after that on the way out
there was a drone attack by the american
military and according to the new york
times we basically killed an afghan
translator and many members of his
family including children rand paul
asked secretary of state tony blinken uh
do you have any idea who he droned and
lincoln's like nope
so question is anyone getting fired for
that like what does it take to get fired
in the pentagon and if you can't get
fired who's actually in control
that's the real question maybe when a
democratic president the answer is the
democratic president is in control but
when a republican president is president
then the bureaucracy is in control here
is senator rand paul with tony blinken
the guy the biden administration droned
was he an aid worker or an isis k
operative
the
administration is of course reviewing
that uh that strike uh and i'm sure that
uh you know full assessment will be will
before you don't know if it was an aid
worker or an isis k operative uh i can't
speak to that and i can't speak to that
in this setting in any event so you
don't know or won't tell us uh i don't i
don't know because we're reviewing it
well see you'd think you'd kind of know
before you off somebody with a predator
drone
yeah
yes i mean sure like
yeah i mean that's kind of hard to argue
with
meanwhile tony blinken keeps saying we
didn't see this coming so then why are
you still working why are you still in
office
and the answer is because if you're part
of the democratic blob you can't lose
your job for pretty much any reasons
other than just kind of offending the
president but other than that you're
gonna stay there forever no matter how
incompetent you are and then when a
republican enters office he's not gonna
fire any of these career staffers he's
gonna keep him there because if he
doesn't keep him there then who's gonna
fill those gaps
the answer is whoever's elected the next
republican president needs to clean
house and i mean mass firings i mean
everybody goes i mean this place gets
shut down top to bottom
here is secretary of state anthony we
had no idea by the way everybody knew
who was watching this for five seconds
this is going to happen if you did this
the way you did it
you didn't take a genius to figure this
out
i wrote a novel like five years ago in
which the first chapter is this
happening
it wasn't because i was watching
afghanistan closely it's because it was
patently obvious to anybody that if you
would draw all support for the afghan
military and hand the country back to
the taliban bad crap was going to follow
here's tony blinken being an idiot
we the intelligence community did not
say
that the countrywide collapse of all
meaningful resistance would be likely to
occur in a matter of days and uh and you
referenced uh chairman milly as i did
earlier
nothing that
that he saw that i saw that we saw
suggested that this government and
security force would collapse in a
matter of 11 days and you're right that
i think we need to look back at all of
this
oh you need to look back at all this but
uh has anybody been fired will anybody
be fired senator josh hawley is asking
that question
yesterday he said that he's going to
slow walk joe biden's foreign policy
nominees until the top officials who
oversaw all of this lose their jobs he
says he's going to object to confirming
nominees for state and defense by
unanimous consent unless anthony blinken
lloyd austin the secretary of defense
and nsa jake sullivan all resign
he says they should take responsibility
for their failures but here's the thing
none of them are going to resign because
their failures are not their own they're
joe biden's failures and if they'd
happened under president trump they
would have obstructing trump's policy
and then trump had fired them there had
been a hue and cry that trump was
getting rid of career officials see when
democrats get rid of career officials or
termed officials it's no big deal
in fact joe biden recently attempted to
fire a bunch of trump appointees to
sort of non-partisan boards in the very
end of his administration and included
some folks like kaylee mcinanny but it
also included some some people like
lieutenant general
like general mcmaster
and biden was like i just don't like you
so i'm gonna try and fire you even
though you actually have terms right
these are not fireable positions
and nobody in the media seem to care
very much about that
norms only exist when they can be used
as a club against republicans
all of this is going to break the
country it really is
by the way are intelligence folks are
they going to get fired because
apparently intelligence experts are now
saying al qaeda could reform inside
afghanistan they originally said it
could reform within one to two years
but apparently al-qaeda's already there
which we already knew so well done
everybody
the reason that i keep coming back to
the centralizing point about the
administrative bureaucracy is because if
the country breaks is going to be
because people there is no incentive
structure for people to stay within the
structure you have to give people
something if you want them to remain
inside a structure that takes 40 percent
of their money 30 of their money and
restricts every area of their life there
has to be some guarantee on the other
end and the guarantee on the other end
cannot simply be that people you
disagree with are going to govern every
aspect of your life
it is why people are seeing movement to
red states as an escape
they are seeing it as a way of avoiding
blue state governance they're they're
moving for a reason the sorting is
happening
and if the response by the democrats and
their friends in the bureaucracy is to
tighten their grip
to harden their defenses
to become more sclerotic
to to become less responsive to cut off
all the feedback loops
you're going to break the thing you are
and that is the direction that we are
moving right now on everything from
defense to afghanistan to kovid
the attempts to to grip everything
incredibly tightly are going to lead to
the you know tummy sort of one said that
coaching a baseball team is sort of like
holding a dove you want to hold it tight
enough that the dove doesn't escape but
you don't want to hold it so tight that
you crush the dove
you could say the federal government is
sort of the same thing that the goal of
the federal government should be to be
strong enough to maintain the union but
not strong enough to actually destroy
the union
and it seems as though we are moving
very rapidly in the direction of strong
enough to destroy the union
and they'd rather crush the dove then
then allow the dove to breathe a little
bit
and the predictable result of that is
not gonna the tighter you grip the more
things are gonna break
you're not creating stability you're
actually creating radical instability in
this entire process and that radical
instability is going to lead to a lot of
very bad things
it's not going to lead to an amicable
amicable breakup like it's not just not
going to be an amicable amicable divorce
the high likelihood is that things get
uglier as time goes on
because in a desire for top down
dominance you are alienating everybody
and when they have no place left to go
because you are using the federal
government as the crammed down power
through the power of an unelected
administrative bureaucracy the only
check apparently being the supreme court
i mean really we now have two branches
of the american government the
administrative state and the supreme
court and that's it
and if the democrats simply pack the
supreme court that check goes away too
then i will say that the end of the
american republican experiment would
would then be at an end
we're in a battle for the culture and
for our values like and subscribe to
help keep our videos on the front line
of the fight and top of your feet